hey what's up guys mkbhd here back with
the fourth and final episode in the
fastest mac mini in the world series so
if you like this little project idea if
you want to see more things like it uh
give this video a thumbs up and i'll
definitely try to get out more similar
stuff for you if you missed the first
three episodes bam they're up there on
the corner they'll open in a new tab so
you can hover over them on your desktop
and those annotations will take you to
the first three episodes so you can see
what's been done to this mac mini but
i'm not going to hold you up let's get
right on into this so if you watch the
first three parts of this project you
probably already know the specs of this
machine it's apple's highest end 2.7
gigahertz intel core i7 2011 mac mini
with a user modified 16 gigabytes of
ddr3 ram and a 240 gigabyte ocz vertex 3
max iops edition ssd inside is the same
mobile motherboard found in the high-end
macbook pros and an amd radeon hd 6630m
graphics card and on top of all this it
runs mac os 10 10.7 lion for the setup
we're going with an apple wireless
keyboard and trackpad i know on the
cyborg rat7 mouse and the fio e9 audio
amplifier on the right and a single dell
ultra sharp 2407 wfp 24 inch monitor you
could go with two of these monitors no
problem you can use the hdmi to dvi
adapter and the thunderbolt to dvi
adapter for a third monitor for an
absolute boss setup like this you'll
need a usb to dvi adapter like this one
to drive the third monitor or each
additional display if you want to go 456
but we like simplicity so let's do some
serious work with this one display so
now it's benchmarking time i pulled on
twitter asking you guys to reply at
mkbhd what i should use to test this
little machine and novabench was a very
popular answer it's a free app that
tests a very well-rounded bunch of
aspects of your machine and comes out
with a final score a final tally for
your mac and at the link in the
description you can see that the fastest
stock mac mini from apple will average
roughly 383 points this mac mini got an
unusually high 835 points which puts it
on the list right beneath the 2008 mac
pro and the 2011 imac but of course
there are more some of your tweets also
suggested at mkbhd i should choose
cinebench which tests graphics and cpu
performance for the graphics test here
which was pretty entertaining to watch
actually it goes through this little
open gl demo sequence here with all
sorts of lighting and shadows and
physics effects and reflections and
things like that and for the cpu
rendering test there was a good
approximation as it renders out these
squares here of how well it would work
with heavy apps heavy hitters like
photoshop and after effects where lots
of rendering is required it didn't
perform great on the cpu test but of
course i am editing this video on the
mac mini so if you see this video on
youtube then i got through it that means
it successfully rendered the video uh
and it did pretty well also actually
really well on the opengl test scoring a
bit below an 8 core 16 thread 2.92
gigahertz intel xenon processor which i
can assume is another mac pro but the
real showstopper here the real
difference maker in the performance is
the ocz vertex 3 ssd this thing flies
through mac os 10. it has insane read
speeds i cannot recommend switching to
an ssd enough if you're still on a
traditional hard drive try this out it's
really insane and makes the biggest
difference in terms of the user
experience and the time it took me to
say that you just watched the mac mini
completely shut down and restart
yeah alright so there's this pretty
popular test out there i don't know if
you've heard of it it's called the ssd
stress test ssd owners like to show off
by opening up as many apps as possible
at the same time
yup it's fast i mean i don't have a ton
of apps installed but there's no chance
in hell your hard drive can do that
seriously solid state is the future so
how fast is this ssd exactly well
let's run the speed test app to find out
it does a few file transfers and the
write speeds look like they're coming in
at around 250 megabytes per second uh
and then it tests the read speeds yeah
holy buns that is fast that's like a
sprinting person fast like cheetah fast
that's like paragraph falcon fast this
isn't a review of the mac mini
necessarily but i can tell you that the
16 gigs of ram really comes in handy for
when i'm video editing like right now
and so the spec lineup is it's really
turns down to it's basically a glorified
macbook pro
and you know does it perform out of this
world for this desktop total price
absolutely check it out mac mini 999 240
gig ocz ssd
480 bucks
16 gigs of ram for other world computing
250 bucks surgery supplies for getting
all the stuff in there 30 bucks total
price
1759.
having the fastest mac mini in the world
on the planet for barely more than the
slowest 27-inch imac
priceless
now look i've never really been a
full-time mac os 10 person but i'm
giving os 10 a shot right now to see if
i can get used to it as my daily driver
as i wait for apple to refresh the mac
pros hopefully as soon as possible with
ivy bridge and i'm honestly going to say
that it won't be so hard to get used to
this right now it's going pretty well my
favorite feature of os 10 lion so far
right now is mission control
i just find myself using it a lot more
and as a person who's used to multiple
monitors it's a really great feature i
definitely recommend picking up a track
pad to take advantage of this because
the mighty mouse magic mouse they suck
and i don't use any of the other
gestures for like launch pad or anything
just for mission control i think launch
pad is just silly
and i know mac people are begging to
know what's in your dock well again i'm
new to os 10 so nothing fancy just yet
nothing freaky going on in here but yeah
guys there you have it it is officially
official this is the new mkp hd desktop
but don't freak out pc people don't lose
it
windows isn't going anywhere
peace guys
[Music]
you